wenn man z.B nicht möchte dass sein
Account gehackt wird im Internet od
sowas das hört man ja immer wieder oh
mein Gott ganz viele Facebook Facebook
Profile wurden gehackt und
ja so ein Tipp den ich zu geben habe
benutzt für alle Seiten auch wenn ihr
euch das nicht merken könnt ein anderes
Passwort oder auch eine andere
E-Mailadresse macht mindestens drei
E-Mailadressen und selbst wenn ihr dann
immer so ein kleines Büchlein mit
Passwörtern bei euch dabei haben müsst
das ist viel besser als wenn ihr das
irgendwie auf einer Datei im Computer
speichert oder sowas oder wenn ihr immer
nur ein Passwort habt weil wenn das
einmal irgendjemand rausfindet wenn das
irgendwo auf irgendeiner Seite rauskommt
dann seid ihr gearscht für immer im
ganzen Internet also das ist mein Tipp
für euch haufenweise passwörte
haufenweise E-Mailadressen dann seid ihr
auf der sicheren
Seite